professor Stein ha how are you today
welcome to modern wisdom hi Chris it's a
pleasure to be here absolutely fantastic
to have you on you're in good company
some of your colleagues from across the
US have been on recently well I'm happy
to be part of their crew so what are we
learning about today well I thought we
might talk about the discovery of a new
form of matter which I've written about
in a recent book it just came out Simon
& Schuster it's called the second kind
of impossible and it's in one sense it's
a science story about this new form of
matter that people once thought was
impossible they thought for centuries
was impossible but it has a lot of other
aspects to the story it's one of the
stranger scientific stories you're
likely to come across Wow so a new kind
of matter yes so there's always with
this question about what ways that exist
for atoms and molecules to come together
to make a piece of matter how they
arrange themselves is very important to
how they behave how that matter behaves
and what it's useful for it depends
partly on the particular kinds of atoms
the chemistry what particular
combination of elements you have but it
also depends upon how they're arranged
so for example we can take carbon and if
we arrange it one way it makes diamond
and if you arrange the atoms another way
it makes graphite the first of course is
transparent and hard the second is very
soft and dark and it's the same
chemistry that carbon chemistry but just
a different arrangement and so that's
been a prime issue in science what are
the different ways mathematically and
physically atoms and molecules can come
together and we thought this subject was
entirely settled by the 1980s in fact
was settled mostly in 19th century
science but what the book is about is
how we were wrong how what we once the
was impossible actually as possible and
and then it goes on to talk about a
strange adventure that that led to that
sounds that sounds absolutely
fascinating so what are the what were
the established understandings of the
the ways that matter could form well the
ways that atoms can come together it was
thought or very much like the ways you
might encounter if you were trying to
say tile your shower floor
okay so let's suppose you were trying to
tie your shower for and I gave you a
bunch of squares I think you're pretty
confident you could tie your shower
floor with squares with just leaving a
little space for grout in between but
they would fit together nicely you can
also imagine and you might even have
hexagons or you might have rectangles or
you might have triangles and you might
have thought there were an infinite
number of possible shapes I could
provide you with but actually there's
only a finite number and full that are
possible if you were tiling your floor
if I gave you perfect Pentagon's and by
a perfect Pentagon I mean all the sides
of the same length and all the angles
are the same
and I asked you to talk and I gave a
bunch of those to you to tile your floor
you might be somewhat embarrassed to
find that it was difficult to put them
together without leaving spaces in
between and that wouldn't be that
wouldn't be very good for your shower no
and and then you might wonder is that
impossible to do or is it just that you
were clever enough to figure out how to
fit them together in this case it's what
I would call the first kind of
impossible something that truly is
impossible something no matter which way
you put them together you know from
rigorous mathematics there's no
conceivable way they can make the
symmetry they can make they can make a
pattern that fills your floor without
tiles your floor without leaving spaces
I got that so there's a beginning one of
the first discoveries that we found is
that if someone gets their bathroom
refitted and the tiler turns up with
pentagon shape tiles that they've got a
hook store on their hands exactly
exactly
already that's right it's not just true
for Pentagon's the same would be true if
they came with heptagon sevenfold or
or nine fold or 11 folder 147 fold so
there are really only five basic
possibilities that you can use and
almost every pattern that you have seen
or humans have seen up until the 1980s
our patterns based on those five
possibilities because we thought
anything else was impossible but we were
wrong it turns out there's more ways to
put if you allow a little bit more
freedom there's more things you can do
than that but before we get to that let
me point out that there's this relates
to the story of matter because matter
forms clusters arrangements of atoms and
three dimensions that fill space just
like building blocks children's building
blocks or just like tiles and two
dimensions and the same restrictions
apply if you ever had a building block
which had the symmetry of a pentagon or
Pentagon's in it then the rule said you
couldn't have matter with that form
either that there were only a restricted
set of possibilities the same issue when
you tried to fit them together they
won't fill space and so atoms hate
having empty space their forces the
strong inter-atomic forces will rip
apart the clusters and they'll make
something else that arrange themselves
into some form that we call a crystal
form an ordinary crystal form like
quartz or salt or sugar and they won't
ever make a form which has a say
fivefold facets facets of a Pentagon so
the you know we know they're of crystals
that have facets which are six sided and
four sided perfect four-sided and
perfect six-sided or three-sided but
never up until the 1980s did we think it
was possible to even put together atoms
or molecules in the way they would have
the symmetries of a pentagon got you so
but there was so it's and and all that
could be shown rigorously mathematically
that is to say it was the first kind of
impossible if you actually tried to
build geometric building blocks in this
way you'll find that you can't
so that was accepted
and it seemed to agree with what we were
finding in nature nature seemed to
reject all these forbidden possibilities
as well so it seemed like a nice tight
complete subject nothing else to be said
well when the when the theoreticians and
the experimentalists all find themselves
in the same camp I guess you've got
you've got a pretty big weight of
academia they're pushing you towards one
particular conclusion exactly in fact it
it would be on the first page of any
book that you picked up on the theory of
solids that said here are symmetries
here are patterns which are allowed
shapes are allowed and here are ones
that are forbidden and Prime among the
forbidden would be anything with the
symmetry of a pentagon but there was a
flaw in that thinking and this and so
you know when when scientists say
something is impossible or at least when
I'm listening as a scientist and the
scientist says something is impossible
that always sort of brings up the
antenna and I begin to wonder you know
which kind of impossible is it is it of
this first kind where it's absolutely
rigorously impossible or is it possible
that they've made some assumption
there's some assumption which they're
not even aware of something that
everyone has been assuming for years
centuries but has not quite true and may
have a loophole in it if you can find
the loophole well then you find
something really interesting you find
something that everyone thought was
impossible to be possible so in this
case we did my student dev levine and i
back in the 1980s discovered a loophole
in this thinking and it goes back to
thinking about tiles and atoms so when i
asked you the question about tiling your
bathroom one thing which i slipped in
there was i was only going to use one
kind of shape now crystals in fact are
all made of one kind of shape of
building block and that building block
repeats just like in a children's
building blocks over and over again with
equal spacing between the blocks okay
and they're all crystals are of that
nature but suppose i allow the
possibility of two building blocks and
suppose i allow the possibility that
they do not repeat in harmony with one
another it's not like shape one shape to
shape one shape to shape aren't shape
two but i have shape one appear at one
frequency or one
rate and shape to appear at a different
rate where their dis harmonic or it's
like an atonal sound or a disharmony of
sound but this is like a disharmony in
space then it turns out what we fetch
showed is that all the rules about
what's allowed and disallowed get broken
you can form shapes with symmetries
tilings now you can fill your bathroom
with those two shapes the entire floor
with the symmetry which has fivefold
symmetry and in fact all the all the
patterns that you thought were
impossible before an infinite number
literally an infinite number of them are
now possible in two dimensions and in
three dimensions so if it's possible
then well maybe you can make in the
laboratory that was the first question
it was theoretically possible that maybe
you can make it in the laboratory and so
we didn't have to wait very long to find
the answer because it turned out a few
hundred miles to the south of us at the
same time that we were thinking of his
radical ideas there was a group led by a
fellow by the name of Dan Shechtman at
the National Bureau of Standards of near
Washington DC and he had accidentally
found a material that absolutely
violated all the laws of matter that
people have learned for centuries in
particular it had symmetries it had
patterns with fivefold symmetry and
could in principle make shapes with five
five fold or pentagon shape facets he
didn't know what to make of it
he just knew it was somehow wrong but he
didn't have a theory to explain it the
theory was being developed a few hundred
miles to the north and we didn't even
know about each other at the time but he
wrote he and his colleagues wrote a
paper we call a preprint sort of
pre-publication version of this paper
sent it to a colleague that I had known
for many years had worked with in the
past the colleague didn't know what I
was doing but he knew I was interested
in these in shapes generally and he
showed up one day in my office and he
said oh I have something to show you I
said I have something to show you
because I want to show underneath
patterns
yeah there was kind of you know we kind
of argued a little bit but it says he
was the visitor I said okay you go first
and he showed me this paper and it was
like amazing because by the time you got
to section two or three of the paper
what it showed was a pattern that you
get that they got by shining electrons
to this material and seeing the pattern
they produced after they passed the
material we call this kind of pattern
and electron diffraction pattern it's
kind of a fingerprint that tells you how
the atoms and molecules are organized
whether they are well organized or
randomly organized and and also the
shape the shape that they're forming and
it showed a very distinctive pattern
that violated the centuries-old rules of
crystallography but I didn't say a thing
because all I had to do was go up to my
desk because on my desk was a
calculation that my student does and I
had done of what you'd expect the
diffraction to be for a quasi crystal I
just picked it up and put the paper next
to the pattern and no they were you know
to the level one could tell by eye the
same so that's so much serendipity as
well it's hilarious they with so many to
end up in your office during the process
that you guys were going through as well
yes because we had we had been holding
back our idea because when I'd been
showing it to people they thought oh
that's kind of interesting curious but
useless because matter will never make
this form and and then by accident
someone did is there an asymmetry there
between the theoreticians and and
experimentalists a little bit like that
if you've got something that's tacit and
kind of appears in real life that
there's there's some more weight to it
in the scientific community then I guess
you've got the fear of presenting a
theory and then it being turned out to
be complete becomes real life yes I mean
especially in this field in the field of
you know studying different forms of
matter like this it's very important
that you don't just have a hypothetical
idea a
imaginative idea it's certainly
important for everyone that I presented
the idea up to that point
it was important that you know you could
actually occur in nature because at
first these patterns
complex until you get used to them it's
hard to see in fact if I show you the
pattern it's a little hard to see what
the but to recognize what's going on in
the pattern but but as you come used to
it begins to have a simplicity but
that's still not the same as showing
that it actually has real physical
relevance that that you can actually
make this in the laboratory and so we
call this so just like the ordinary
ordinary ordered forms of matter where
you have regular repeating building
blocks we call those crystals we call
this new form of matter quasi crystals
quasi because when you have patterns
that are composed of two or more
elements that have repeated dis harmonic
frequencies mathematicians call that
quasi periodic and they call crystals
periodic so we called ours quasi
crystals formation yeah
and that's how the subject began that
was and that's kind of the prelude to
the story if you like which explains why
we were why I was interested in the
story of quasi crystals in the first
place because they represented new forms
of matter which would have new physical
properties and there'd be an infinite
variety to be discovered a whole new
world and and and this field kind of
took off from there but in terms of what
I was doing
we took a I took a strange turn which
was to I was curious if we had made
these things in the laboratory why isn't
that we had never seen them in nature
that was my you've taken the questions
right off the end emitter good question
okay thank you you know lots of crystals
in nature there are thousands of
different types of crystals in nature
how come we've never once you know
thousands of years ago or hundreds of
years ago or decades ago seeing a quasi
crystal before is it because it's
impossible is there something that's
forbidding it's some people in the field
thought so they said these things are so
complicated you'd only be able to make
them in the laboratory we can control
the conditions just so put the elements
together just so that they'd make this
structure but the way we had come to the
idea of quasi crystals was not just
thinking of them as building
so I'll show you a little piece of a
three-dimensional tiling here it's a
three dimensional tiling which is a
piece of a quasicrystal it's kind of a
layer of a quasicrystal yeah yeah for
the listeners listeners who are just on
audio would you be able to describe to
the best of your ability as well please
sure so this particular structure
contains four different types of tiles
therefore they're shown in the image in
four different colors some are small
some are medium some are large and
they're fitting together in a pattern
which if you look at the center of it
would have an obvious center of fivefold
symmetry and but there's more to this
than that it they're held together by
Lego like joinings but the Lego like
joinings are not all the same and they
have a special property which is that if
I gave you a roomful of these units and
asked you to fill the room full of them
the only way you could put them together
without leaving spaces would be to make
a quasi crystal pattern you could never
put them together to make a pattern
which has the symmetry of a crystal okay
so this is forcibly quasi periodic not
just allowing it but only allowing it
yes now what why do why is that
important because it means if you get
atoms do the same thing they couldn't
form the crystal they could only form
the quasi crystal and it added and if
you could find configurations of atoms
that have that and they happen to exist
in nature well voila you'd have what you
what you're looking for so why not why
couldn't this happen in nature why
couldn't there be such a thing okay so
okay so how do you go about looking for
this well the first thing you might do
is go to museums which is what I did I
went to museums and saw if there was
anything in a display case that maybe
had not been identified that that's kind
of what I did at first what you mean
like remains and are you talking about
exotic material well I didn't know you
know I until I go to the museum I don't
know what to find what museums were you
going to what were you actually looking
at what was in the clothes in the cases
well so usually when you go to a museum
your eye is taken by the really
large examples of crystals that are
pretty famous and those are not going to
be misidentified but usually in display
cases they're hidden below drawers and
things like that and in the back rooms
of museums you'll find lots and lots of
materials which are less familiar which
are less studied so I was kind of hoping
that be lucky so I went to the American
Museum of Natural History I went to the
Smithsonian Institute in Washington
Natural History Museum in Washington but
none of that yielded anything so that
was that turned out not to look nice day
out but yeah beautiful day out because
these specimens are beautiful and
fascinating and you know but yeah no
such luck so it took about 15 years
before I began to think of a systematic
way of searching for quasicrystals and
it involved looking for computer data
looking through computer databases of
electron diffraction patterns so I could
study many at once and use various
mathematical tricks to search for ones
that might be quasi crystals or nearly
quasi crystals and then we tried to find
them my collaborators and I would try to
find them bring them here to Princeton
slice them and dice them and see if they
really were quasi crystals or not so it
spent several years developing with it
with a bright student named Peter Liu I
spent several years developing the
mathematics and then actually doing the
test and there were many many adventures
and just collecting the materials but
the end of a few years no such luck oh
what years we got now where are we now
is this still 80's 90's so this was 1998
when we started and by 2001 while Peter
had now graduated he was an
undergraduate he graduated and gone on
to do something else
most the team was disseminated by the
end we wrote the paper and we asked but
we asked if anyone wants to join our
little search right us because we'd be
loving we'd love to have someone join
our search and unfortunately no one
answered that that call but then six
years later suddenly somebody did I
suddenly
got an email from an Italian
mineralogist head of the Museum of manal
mineralogy in Florence
his name was Luca bhindi never heard of
him before the University of Florence is
not a you know it's a nice but not you
know a major-league mineralogy museum
but Luca volunteered to help us with
whatever he had in his museum and more
importantly he volunteered his
incredible enthusiasm and energy almost
immediately he became as fanatical about
this search as I was exactly like a
Florence mineralogist as I imagine one
in my mind well I think that like just
full of energy and bouncing around the
room this is definitely Luca and and
actually his answering the car was one
of the luckiest things that happened in
the entire search because now when I was
now been going I guess this was that say
when he answered the calls like 2009 we
began the search I guess 25 years
earlier so this was the biggest joke of
luck both because of his enthusiasm
because of his talent and then it turned
out he had something in his museum that
we didn't couldn't possibly have
anticipated which was well I should go
back one step and say so we started the
process with him or I started the
process with him I had a list of
possible candidates for him to look at
he he tamed them he sliced them and
diced them and no lock failure failure
failure and then he finally suggested
that there was some he had a collection
of interesting minerals in the story
storage room of his museum there were in
a set of drawers and one of them to him
seemed rather promising because it had a
chemistry which is similar to a known
quasi crystal one that had been found in
the laboratory so so he tried that one
and he sliced and diced it and he found
there were some tiny little grains in
there that looked very promising he
glued those onto the edge of a tiny
glass needle sent those to Princeton
brought to Princeton and and when we
looked at it under the electron
microscope amazingly enough it produced
a beautiful quasi crystal pattern
just the diffraction pattern that one
would imagine mathematically much more
perfect than the sample that was found
back in 1984 the first example which was
rather sloppy highly defected one this
was as good as anything man-made that I
had ever seen but it was not made by
manner didn't seem to be it was in the
middle of this very complicated little
rock if the rock was tiny was only a you
know about a few millimeters a few
centimeters big yeah but it contained
lots of minerals and there and mixed in
there you know jumbled up with
everything else mixed in with everything
else needed in with everything else with
these little grains and so okay we that
could have been victory that could have
been the end of the story we could have
just said we found it you know Eureka
okay and written a paper but as
throughout the story every time you
think we're done you know another
question emerges and the obvious
question is the would you have asked why
is it only in such small small amounts
why is it so rare okay there's a good
question and how is it that nature
managed to make the quasicrystal under
conditions into which none of us would
have ever thought to make it in the
laboratory because these quasi crystals
in this case this particular example
contain aluminum copper and iron it's a
metal alloy in this case and those are
highly reactive metals and they love to
interact with oxygen and all the stuff
around them is full of oxygen so you'd
never try to make a quasi crystal in an
environment which is anywhere close to
oxygen when we make in a laboratory we
very carefully isolate the metals and
cool them slowly this rock was clearly
cooled quickly in some places and
there's oxygen all over the place so
question what is nature figured out that
we don't know and that actually is when
the real adventure begins because to
answer that question took us on sort of
international journey of detective story
intrigue and mystery that took us that
occupied us for the next few years
that sounds it sounds I'm reading The Da
Vinci Code at the moment in amongst all
of the nonfiction I'm going through and
this sounds like the the mineralogists
version of The DaVinci Code it isn't a
sense it is it's definitely the
strangest story you'll ever see it
required its years of I'd say
extraordinary stubbornness on our part
because there were so many points when
when it seemed impossible to complete
this or even to get started and you know
and every time it seemed impossible
something would happen that would save
the day and get the story started again
so just to get just to start with that
the first thing I did is I tried to find
if there was famous geologists on campus
who knew something about how rocks
formed to ask him well okay here's our
sample tell me what does it say how did
nature figure out to do this his name is
Lincoln Hollister he's very well known
he's one of the first people to study
lunar rocks so he had seen all kinds of
strange rocks and formations and he
studies exactly this question given a
rock how do you interpret our how do you
figure out how it formed so I went to
Lincoln's office which is a Princeton
and not gonna store it I told him the
story I just told you and you sat them
he thought for a moment and sort of gave
me a strange look he said okay Paul I
hate to tell you this but what you have
there is impossible I said no it's not
impossible Lincoln we know these quasi
crystals exist we even know this
particular one can be made in the
laboratory and what he interrupted me he
said no I'm not nothing about the
quasicrystal bothers me it's this
business that you're telling me that
this quasi crystal has metallic aluminum
in it the earth is full of aluminum is
the third most common element in the
earth but it's all attached to oxygen
aluminum loves oxygen it will never
you'll never find it in nature without
oxygen present so I'm sorry but what you
have there is some sort of you know
refuse from laboratory or some
industrial byproducts being contaminated
somehow that's it's yeah it's not
natural so we were ready to celebrate
but he was telling us no it's he's pooed
on you parade
exactly exactly now fortunately
because I've had experience with this
issue of impossible before I didn't stop
I asked him next I said when you say
it's impossible do you mean like truly
impossible like one plus one is three
but I would call them first kind of
impossible or do you mean just very
unlikely or impossible according to
common assumptions but if true might be
really interesting and at that point
Lincoln could easily have thrown me out
his window or out of his office but he
didn't he stopped and he thought for a
moment and he said well if I were forced
to come up with an idea for this you'd
have to it can't be formed on the
surface of the earth or it have to be
formed deep deep deep under the surface
of the earth near the boundary between
the metallic core and the the mantle and
then you have to figure out a way to get
it from there to the surface but you
know there have been geologists
including my department who have
hypothesized that one time there were
plumes like plumes that would carry
material up from the core all the way to
the surface of the earth that at one
time existed and if so it could have
been carried up very quickly and kept
its form and I thought to myself oh it's
very unlikely and bizarre that the story
is true but it's not impossible and if
true it's not possible second kind of
impossible and if two really really
interesting which then suddenly made it
much more important to figure out what
it was well you've got geological
implications now and right and then I
and then I and then I asked him a
question which I thought which I've been
thinking about but which I've been
thinking about which is well how about
maybe was made in space maybe it's part
of a meteorite because I said stupidly
there is no oxygen in space and that
would protect it from the oxygen I
didn't know at the time but that was a
really stupid comment because there's
lots of oxygen in space I just didn't
know it I'm a theoretical physicist who
normally works on other subjects this is
all new to me so so and then linking the
fortunately again didn't throw me out of
his office he just said well I actually
don't know that much about meteorites
I'll take but I know someone who does
he's at the Smithsonian in Washington
I'll take you down there to meet him
next week and so we did and when I got
to the fellow in Washington his name is
Glenn Macpherson even before I got into
the Smithsonian was already waiting at
the outside door he knew we were coming
from the train station
he was already waiting at the outside
door before I could say anything other
than hello
immediately began to tell me how what we
had was absolutely impossible did you
when you arrived did you think I know
what this guy's gonna say - I've heard
this one before no no I was hoping you
would tell me something brilliant that
oh this is very exciting you've
discovered a new kind of meteorite
professor this is what I've been waiting
for yet we weren't you Eirik a few years
ago and looking at all of the rocks in
the back room yeah yeah so so then the
next few hours is just giving us reason
reason reason after that why this
couldn't possibly be a meteorite and so
that's what began what is the real
adventure detective part of the story
was what could we do we could number one
try to determine where this rock came
from was it really not natural where
where Lincoln Hollister and Glenn
McPherson write that it had to be there
was impossible to really make in nature
that had to be you know some sort of
human bright by-product or is it
possible that we're missing something
yeah
so how improbable let's say that it was
a contaminated sample how improbable is
it that something that was produced by
humans and then and contaminated a
particular sample would have had this
structure that you're talking about
because it seems like it's even man-made
is an incredibly rare structure to have
found that's a great question Chris and
that word for me was prime motivation
because even though they were telling me
what we had wasn't natural somehow even
through some random industrial process
had been made in a way that we didn't
know so I thought that was kind of some
degree in a no-lose situation someone in
Florence who's got a crazy production
technique or there's something bigger
and more grand at foot right right so so
what do you do well we did kind of two
things at the same time one operation
was a detective story trying to actually
trace where this little rock came from
and the other was to take the few little
grains microscopic grains of the
material that were left now because most
have been pulverized in the process of
getting up to this point and use those
to study in the laboratory any sign that
would tell us for sure it's some sort of
industrial process or sure it's not
and those substitutes both those two
stories evolved
simultaneously over the or in sync it's
in sync over the next two years so
almost every day there was something
happening in one or the other almost
every day Luca Vindi and I were skyping
and there was either some some news some
disaster occasionally some miracle
happening along the way okay one thing I
checked with about here was did Luca
have like a handling history for the
piece of material because that would
have I'm gonna guess at least start you
off in the right direction good another
great question Chris you're following
you're finding the detective story
perfectly if you ever need if you need
an assistant
I got British accent you come from the
land of Sherlock Holmes and dr. Watson
so they call on me when you meet me well
this is very appropriate because the
detective is exactly what was needed and
so that's the first thing we did we look
in the in the records of the museum we
found that the that the records show
that the this sample along with 3,000
other samples had been sold by a
collector who lived in Amsterdam it told
us the name of the collector the name of
the collector but did not tell us at
address of how to find him and it had
been sold in around 1990 but with a name
we could now this is the modern day of
the internet you know you can go on the
internet and you can literally walk the
streets of Amsterdam talk to people in
Dutch which I don't speak using Google
Translate and search for it to see if
you can find this missing collector and
at the end of number of weeks of trying
to do this
no such luck and no finding then the
next thing we did so almost
simultaneously was to search collections
around the world because no there's
nothing
that's special about the Florence Museum
or this rock so far as we knew this
material so we started sending alerts to
museums there's various internet sites
which collectors use who collect
minerals and we got something like five
takers five people who claimed that they
had samples of this material for in the
West and one was in a museum in Russia
how do you how do you send that sort of
a broadcast out well there's actually
for collectors of minerals there's a
website called mind at comm and
collectors use it to exchange
information about minerals and they I
think they use it to I think also
mineral sellers you know people collect
minerals they pay for them it's like
it's like a eBay for rocks yeah so it's
very much so this also contains but it's
more than the seller it's contains all
the scientific information so you can
read the properties of your mineral you
can see pictures of it you can learn
something about the history of it so so
we look for that so that's and then they
also we can put out alerts so it's an
it's a nice community in this sense and
when we got the four samples from the
west and we tested them we discovered
they were all fakes that's to say they
were not the mineral that we thought
they didn't have aluminum copper and
iron them they were all fake so this is
another side of mineralogy which if you
ever collect minerals one has to be
aware of which is there's a lot of
fakery in the minerals game rocks other
counterfeit rocks because you know when
you buy art and it's a valuable art you
you darn well get it verified by experts
but rocks are not nearly that expensive
so you know someone says I have a novel
kind of rock that maybe you read about
in some mineral magazine as being a new
newly discovered mineral okay you're
gonna buy it and you may you know you
you don't have the money or the
machinery to test it so you're not going
to do say just going to put in your
collection and some of these were museum
collections that I were they were it had
them but what happened as a collector
donated their collection including the
fake to the museum and the museum did
the same thing it doesn't have time to
check all of it so that's how it ends up
in museums
and even today because the story I'm
telling you is now become somewhat
famous this mineral can be found at
Mineral shows we've bought it from the
mineral shows to check if anyone
actually had found something legitimate
and we've yet to find something
legitimate so if you find these
materials claims of quasicrystals at
Mineral shows and they're very big ones
around the world like at munich and in
tucson arizona beware buyer beware I'll
ring you bring you inside yes right but
you see it doesn't work like that you
have to buy first take your risk and buy
come take your electrode the microscope
over there and just you won't get your
money back that's put it that way as far
as I know the show will have you know
have clothes that people who have
disappeared and no I don't think it
works that way my mind that needs PayPal
seller protection and buyer protection
and they're really done they that would
that would stop all of this in its
tracks it would but it requires the
testing now the advantage was which work
in our favor was because it's so
expensive to test mineral collectors and
you ask when you offer to test will snap
up the offer and that's why they sent us
the samples because you might wonder why
would they send us their valuable
samples well they want to verify because
if it was correct they win and if it's
not correct okay they understand there's
a certain amount of that's part of the
risk of the of the business you know
when you or the other color being in the
collection business will accept it but
the one in Russia we knew was real
because when the the mineral that is
contained inside along with the
quasicrystal is there's a mineral in
there which is an ordinary crystal
mineral which had been discovered first
and published and officially accepted by
the International mineralogical
Association and when you get a new
mineral accepted by the International
mineral Association you have supposed to
put one in the museum a copy a version
of it the museum which becomes sort of
the standard sample if case anyone ever
wants to prove that that mineral
actually exists it's kept but but
same token you're not allowed to fiddle
with that sample so we couldn't test it
they wouldn't allow us the only the
museum director would not let us test it
so he couldn't do it that way so that
what do you do next while you try to
find the people who claim to have
discovered that mineral back in the
1980s yeah so it turns out well again
going on the internet we discovered the
person we discovered who were the
authors of the paper that first
submitted it and then we began to search
it turned out to be a Russian and we
searched throughout Russia for this
person we discovered that he was once
that he was at the time that he claimed
to find this new mineral head of the
Institute of platinum this is the 1980s
Soviet times head of an Institute of
platinum platinum is a very valuable
defence material this is a guy that you
do not want to mess about with exactly
in fact we we heard some pretty bad
stories about him what he did with his
competitors shady yeah so I think that's
I don't want to go too far in that
statement you can say that I can say I
can call them shady all you want but he
was no he was he you know had various
friends of his or his purported to have
various competitors of his I should say
you know arrested yeah yeah it's
supposed to have or removed it from
sight at least so they were no longer
competitors of his we also learned they
had emigrated to Israel so the next
thing we did you know was try to the
same deal in Israel walking the streets
of Israel fine and looking through the
phone books I found someone with that
name called him up and he didn't speak
English so I got a you know Hebrew
speaker door and called him up and he
didn't speak Hebrew got a Russian
speaker and of course he does speak
Russian and he verified that he was the
guy that was on this paper that was the
first thing he when I asked him to see
the person who actually picked that rock
out of the ground he said yes and I
thought that was great because now I
could found out a lot more about whether
it was discovered near a factory or
somewhere in the middle of nowhere and
then I asked him about his geological
notebook where
his notebook that describing his
discovery and that's when things got a
little strange because he said I'm not
sure and you have to know that if you're
a geologist you always know day and
night any time of day or night
throughout your life exactly where your
geological notebook is it's something
you live with and record in it's like a
diary you know it's something okay
so so the fact that he hesitated on that
was a huge red flag I've been warned by
Lincoln Hollister to watch out if he
said he didn't know his g11 and then I
asked him does he have more samples he
said well maybe the geological notebook
and maybe there are more samples back in
Moscow and I look up the price of flying
him from Tel Aviv to Moscow and it
wasn't a bad I said okay what if I fly
you there would you be willing to go
retrieve it he said yes but and then it
took a while it's not just that
conversation but several conversations
to figure out what he really wanted was
a rather significant reward for doing
that beyond the price of going to and
from Moscow and now it's really worried
because he wasn't able to answer any of
my questions about details and he might
well go back come back with a notebook
but how would I know when I was written
and he might say they couldn't find any
more samples and you know how could I so
yeah so it's a really tough decision
should I let this go because is the last
thread left and the whole story that
connects us to where this sample where a
sample might have come from
but eventually I did gave up on him I
decided not to pursue it and so this was
kind of one of those moments of
impossibility we had now looked at every
through every museum every collection
that we could get our hands on and the
one person who definitely had a similar
material and all those all those had
reached dead ends and then one of those
things happen which is one of the
miracles that repeated throughout the
story that sort of keeps you on the hook
keeps kept us on the hook even when
things look dire which just began with a
simple dinner in Florence Luca having
dinner with his sister and a friend of
hers that she had brought to dinner and
the friend is not even a scientist but
he lives in Amsterdam and so when Luca
tells him the part of the story about
there being a collector in Amsterdam he
says oh I live in Amsterdam what's the
name of the collector and he tells him
the name of the collector he says ah
that's too bad that's a very common last
name like Smith or Jones or something
like that and so that's not going to
help you to find this person but he said
there is an old woman who lives down the
street from me I helped her collect
groceries she has that last name when I
get back home tomorrow I'll just ask her
just just off on the off-chance okay so
24 hours later an email comes and he
explains guess what she's the widow of
the collector no way yeah and some out
of nowhere so as you can imagine you
know the next day Luca is there in
Amsterdam Amsterdam absolutely which is
such a long distance but you know but
but yeah you know I wanted to show up
she won't talk to him directly because
she's a little intimidated but she will
talk to the friend and the friend asked
her you know does she know about her
husband's collection no no he was the
collector she knows nothing about the
collection he says well did he ever talk
about his collection no no he never
talked about his collection that was
just his business and his business alone
and this went on for about now we're
asking every possible way does she know
anything whatsoever anything any tidbit
of information she can offer about the
sample and finally she says well I
really know nothing about the sample
I've been telling you that but my
husband used to keep a secret diary and
while the collection was sewn sold to
Florence I kept the secret diary the
sun's like the notebook exactly except
it was a notebook of a collector rather
than a notebook of a geologist so it's
where he purchased he was purchasing
minerals like a leg up like a ledger
that's right and sure enough she brings
forth a notebook and in the notebook it
shows this sample it explains that he
got that sample he well he exchanged
things for that sample in Romania
doesn't it yes and with a fellow by the
name of Tim Tim the Romanian and and of
course it's tickled it's strictly
illegal that would be considered
smuggling to smuggle minerals out and
during Soviet times so he it was
carefully described you know in sort of
careful terms how this exchange was done
and when I heard the news when we heard
the news of this I thought wow this is
the this is with all the steps and we've
had to follow this will be the easiest
step to follow finding a Romanian named
Tim whose mother
let's take a day a week for two weeks
you know but six weeks later no Jim and
in fact I can tell you I've never found
Tim the Romanian so this is again
another dead end and so as a last
desperate desperate attempt we send Luca
back to Amsterdam to see maybe maybe her
husband told his wife something about a
Romanian named Tim so so again the
conversation goes this time she's
willing to talk to Luka and Luca is
asking her and their friends ask her
again and again if you ever heard of
this fellow named Tim know anything
about a Romanian know anything about
this trip to Romania no no no no nothing
I remember nothing at all nothing to do
with me or anything and then after she
reaches a point of exhaustion she
finally confesses that although she
really honestly knows nothing her
husband used to also keep a secret
secret diary for probably the most
questionable purchases in his collection
and she brings that out and there it
explains that on this trip to Romania he
met this fellow Tim and that where Tim
is getting his samples from it's from a
particular laboratory and st. Petersburg
exactly the laboratory that our fellow
in Israel had been using all the time
for all his work and mineralogy work so
now we know our sample isn't just
similar chemically to the material that
this fellow in Israel had we know it is
actually the same stuff it's a piece of
the same stuff he took some of the
minerals and he put one piece in the
museum so he could claim a new mineral
but then the rest of it somehow got out
of the country in exchange for something
you know smuggling operation and so now
we know where we have to look for our
sample we have to look for wherever this
guy really got it in the first place but
this point we don't trust that he
actually is the person that picked him
out of the ground we've heard enough
stories and he but somebody did and who
is it and I'll save you that part of the
story to say it another detective story
eventually led us to find the person who
actually physically picked it out of the
ground back in 1979 and brought it back
to this fellow who was in Israel he was
a student at the time working for him in
this remote area far eastern Russia in
the in the northern half of the
kamchatka peninsula which is about as
far north as far east as you can get in
Russia so I mean that's like barren
wasteland stuff right
yes it's across a tundra in a set of
mountains called the koryaks which you
know so so if you look at the if you've
if you've ever looked at a map of the
Kamchatka Peninsula it's right across
the Bering Strait from Alaska okay and
it's and although people usually when
you think of northern Russia they think
of Siberia
it's actually geologically not part of
Siberia it's the one part of northern
Russia which is not part of Siberia it's
a part of a tectonic plate which crashed
into Siberia at some earlier stage along
with the stuff that makes up Alaska and
California and so it's exotic
geologically the southern half you can
visit these days the northern half is
still restricted even Russians average
Russians cannot go there is restricted
for well historically for defense
purposes because it's the part of Russia
that's closest to the US territory and
partially for mining purposes it's rich
in mining material so miners can go
there there are American mining
companies there but it's for historical
reasons various historical reasons
restricted and and when we found him he
you know pointed out exactly on the map
were where this was which helped us to
at least recover some information
and he offered if we were ever and I
would say crazy enough to want to go
back and look for more material he'd be
happy to help us which was important if
they ever needed to do it now at the
time I didn't think I'd ever think about
going back but in the meantime something
else happened the laboratory that we
didn't expect which is where we were
studying these grains that were that
were left from there from the original
Florence sample we discovered after
about two years we discovered a number
of things that told us it was very
likely natural but we finally found sort
of the killer measurement which showed
us that the material was likely to have
come from a meteorite exactly the thing
that Glenn Macpherson had said it
couldn't have been and a meteorite that
wouldn't was just an ordinary meteorite
most meteorites form rather recently in
the Solar System more recently in the
solar system this one is as old as the
solar system in fact it's formed before
the earth formed formed before the
planets formed so we have a meteorite
which has a quasi crystal in it we have
possibly a meteorite which has a quasi
crystal in it which may have formed
before the planets formed which means
it's also connected to the formation of
the planets it's in telling us not only
was there was an exotic process that
formed a quasi crystal but somehow it's
a process which geologists and meteorite
experts and physicists didn't know about
still don't completely know about that
nature figured out before there were
even planets and may have something to
do with the core of planets mature
metals that make up the core of planets
so suddenly this was a much more
important story than then then simply
what was already an amazing story which
is finding a quasi crystal and then but
we couldn't investigate any further
because we were out of sample all the
samples were spent so so the only way
they'd possibly get and he would be to
go back to this remote place across the
tundra to the Koryak mountains of the
northern half of could come jaw invade
Russia the way to get more of this is to
invade Russia effectively which means
you know you have if you don't want to
if you actually would like to get out
safely maybe with your samples maybe you
want to get their permission but that
means you have to get
from the Russian government you have to
get permission from the FSB you have to
get permission from the Russian military
then chacorta this northern half of
Kamchatka Peninsula itself has its own
government its own it's its own
restrictions bureaucratic nightmare sort
of a pile of paperwork which you know it
does which is hugely which is huge you
have to pull together a team that's
willing to go with you and Crimmins the
other thing that's that's hard
potentially without any permission well
you're gonna get the permissions you're
gonna get there you're gonna have to get
all the permissions in time to be able
to go you're gonna have to get money to
be able to go no self-respecting
agencies federal agency or museum is
gonna pay you for that because any
geologist would tell you it's crazy some
guy found a grain in 1979 you're gonna
go back and you think there's any chance
that he can find it even if you could
find the area that you're gonna find
even a second grain you know the chances
are you know but you guess you know a
hundred percent of thousands of percent
of success on the other hand if you
don't go there's no chance of success so
but at this point I've only told you
some of these strange things in the
story by this point you have to imagine
we're all in at least I'm all in and
Luca is all in you just have to take the
story wherever it goes so even though
it's taking us someplace crazy we go
yeah we all together pull together a
team I get someone a private donor to
provide the money for us I all together
America combination of Americans and
regressions and Luca Italian to go with
us that includes my son who's a at the
time was an undergraduate student at Cal
Tech in geophysics and going on his way
to Harvard he joins the team he's my
tent-mate
everyone on the team is explained one
thing everyone the team is an
experienced geologist of some sort
including my son is an experienced
camper and outdoorsman except for one
person which is big yes so but never but
you know and I actually hope to send
them without having to go myself
for various reasons I won't you know you
have to read the book to find out why I
got trapped into going as well so so
very were in in July 2011 you know this
team going off to them literally across
the tundra and two strange-looking
vehicles behemoth vehicles working their
way across the tundra sort of a roller
coaster ride across the tundra for for
four days to get to this obscure dream
stream in the quarry acts where in 1979
Valeri creates Co this Russian who had
found what had found this earlier
mineral and and then the story doesn't
end being crazy there because you know
when you get there you can't bring your
electron microscope there either so what
can you do you just collect and collect
and collect material as much as you can
you pan it like you pan for gold because
you know it has to have a little higher
density than ordinary minerals and you
just bring back as much as you can not
knowing if you found anything at all and
then when you get back you have now have
millions of grains collected from up and
down the stream and all you can do is
look at them one by one by one by one by
one and with realizing that your chances
are nil of anything but Luka who I call
the worm Odom Oracle II which means
miracle man you know six weeks later
actually said I should say in the field
he thought he had identified a sample
and six weeks later when he actually had
a chance to study in the laboratory it
sure enough proved to have a piece of
quasi crystal in there exactly the same
kind that was in Florence attached to a
piece that was now unquestionably a
piece of a meteorite so we were we're
pretty confident when we went that it
was associated the meteorite but now
there was no doubt and in fact this
whole story which I reconstructed for
you this detective story
there are various points in the story
you might wonder well have we followed
the right trail in him out you know
maybe we missed a trip maybe we were
stake in one place or another well now
that we found the material ourselves in
the same place we knew at that moment
that that whole crazy story was true so
we had actually solved the mystery we
had been the good shirt
combs detectives and and solve the
mystery correctly but more than that
we now knew we had more material to look
at and but that we've so far found nine
different grains and little by little
been putting preaching together the
story of you know when this meteorite
came to earth some of the story of what
happened to it in space some of the
bizarre things that underwent we've been
able to reproduce some of the conditions
in the laboratory this meteorite
underwent very intense high-impact
collisions in space and that has
something to do with the story how they
formed it's we've been able to reproduce
some of that in space and we're learning
from that new ways to make quasicrystals
that from nature that we didn't know
we're possible before and that's where
the story is right now there's still
many things we don't understand
and that will be where the story goes
from here that's an absolutely
mind-blowing story I genuinely think
that a novel made from this would be
would be good reading so the thing that
super cool is your your first assumption
or your first kind of hope I guess to
make it a little bit more exciting and
interesting was that this would be
something which was created naturally
and wasn't something which had been
contaminated that was correct but
terrestrial was incorrect correct that's
right we still don't have an example yet
of a terrestrially made at earthbound
quasicrystal doesn't mean it's
impossible it just means we haven't
found it yet we haven't found an example
yet we've been focusing almost all this
time on this one understanding the
origin of this one sample because it
over time it accreted all this other
important and other importance like its
connection to the early solar system
so we've really been trade you know
focusing almost all our effort towards
that but we'll swing back towards
looking for terrestrial ones or maybe
now that I hope we also hope that we
would inspire other people to look and
maybe someone will find one before us
invade Russia so um as a kind of a
concluding thought then if you were to
put your academic money where your mouth
is with regards to this what what do you
think is the reason that these
particular structures are formed why are
they formed in this particular way and
why does it only seem to happen in space
or why what's the reason for it
occurring and then what are the
implications for us being able to create
materials does this allow us to make
soup anything that's super strong or
super useful or super conductive good
questions
so over the years we've collected a
number of possible theories of how this
may be made in space some of which have
now been eliminated by experiments we've
done since then but I think that two
leading candidates are mine in my mind
are number one what you might call solar
lightning so in the early solar
formation the Sun of the solar system
there was all this dust that was
surrounding the Sun before there were
planets and dust can pick up charge and
as it rubs against each other a bangs
into each other and some have speculated
that this produces lightning and
lightning is one way of detaching
aluminum from OC's luminance of oxygen
or could it's potentially some way of
doing that and so we've been thinking
about that idea and thinking about
adapting that in the laboratories and
not of lightning but some version of
electrical charges of making quasi
crystals that way
another idea is that what we see in some
meteorites of this early age is that
there are pieces of them that that
actually come from a different solar
system they existed before this solar
system before the Sun ignited they have
what are called pre solar grains and
some of them are have been identified
already in meteorites they're they're
quite different than the quasicrystals
but maybe our quasicrystals are examples
of these pre solar grains that would be
formed from nearby astronomical events
like the collision of two stars
collision of two neutron stars or
something like that producing a metal
rich material without producing less
oxygen that's what you'd have to look
for and we don't have this is not a very
well developed idea it's still early
stages but there would be another kind
of idea so it might actually be a
visitor not just from outer space but
for me even a different solar system
either way it's telling us there are
processes that occurred in space
probably not just once but quite
frequently in space long before most of
the minerals that we know on earth
existed a lot of the minerals that are
on earth are formed only after life
formed on earth and the atmosphere
became filled with oxygen and and and
what was on the earth reacted with
oxygen if you go back to these early
stages of the solar system they were
probably there only there weren't that
many different minerals existing but now
we know one of them on the list is a
quasi crystal in fact I should say it's
not the only one on the list there are
three quasi crystals because by the time
we got to this stage in the in the late
stages of the investigation we didn't
just find our original quasi crystal we
found two other chemical compositions
that made quasi crystals this meteorite
was full of quasi crystals those made up
what was the characteristic of the
structure of the other two so one of
them was a mixture of aluminum nickel
and nickel and iron so iron nickel are
very common in meteorites so the added
element was the aluminum as opposed to
aluminum copper and iron which was the
first one and it was interesting it's
especially interesting because whereas
the first sample had this symmetry of a
soccer ball or a football with lots and
lots of fivefold Pentagon faces or
Pentagon symmetries
this new one only had sort of was it was
a stack a regular stacking of layers
each of which had the symmetry of a
decagon 10-fold symmetry it was a
different kind of quasi crystal not just
different chemically but different
symmetry different different category so
we found two different
categories and the third guy turns out
to have the same chemical composition
and I should say for these first two
they were ones we already knew existed
in the laboratory
they've been scared to go long decades
ago
but now we found them in the meteorite
the third one is again aluminum copper
and iron but the different composition
than the first and that competition
would never been seen in the laboratory
before so that's the first example of a
quasi crystal that nature made and that
we discovered in nature before we made
it in the laboratory well so we've since
made in the laboratory by using a
technique which is not unlike what the
way the meteorite created it which is
basically bashing together stuff
together at high speed at supersonic
speeds so we've learned something from
nature and and and then you ask well why
would you care about that besides
curiosity why do you care well because
if you have new classes of materials
with new symmetries new tines the kinds
of atomic arrangements then all their
properties their their hardness their
like bend ability or hardness there
there's slipperiness like Teflon like
slipperiness the all their property
electronic properties all those
properties are going to be different in
some ways that and you're going to what
you're going to want to do is find
examples that have the ideal chemistry
and the ideal physical properties for
whatever application you have in mind
so already we do use quasi crystals and
applications we want materials made of
aluminum alloys but harder than typical
aluminum alloys in fact it turns out by
accident
we've already been using quasi crystals
without knowing it there are certain
there are certain and airplane materials
that are used to sheathe airplanes which
had been used for years but never
studied and the electron microscope yeah
and by accident when people studied it
they discovered it contained grains of
quasicrystals and it had been optimized
to be a hard aluminum alloy and they
didn't realize that what they were doing
by accident was making something that
was full of these quasi crystal grains
I'm making
they were as a byproduct of that
creating the quasicrystals which was
actual reason for the structural
integrity exactly without knowing that
what they were doing is you can that can
happen in in in the materials game so
you discover after the fact but of
course then you can optimize once you
know that you can optimize and so there
are quasi crystals which are used for
industrial parts and the like for the
under the under these kinds of
circumstances but then another kind of
application which is which is to make
involves the making synthetic quasi
crystals by that I mean is I showed you
this structure over here in this pattern
imagine that I take each of these edges
and I turn it into a kind of a link and
I make a network of those links rather
than a network of solids and then
imagine I shrink that to microscopic
scale it turns out that kind of
structure has a very interesting
property when you pass light through it
it treats light much the way a
semiconductor like Silicon or germanium
treats electrons it for it's a kind of
semiconductor for light now without
saying in too much detail what that
means you know that semiconductors play
a key role in the electronics and
industry everything in computers
everything in your cell phone relies on
integrated circuits which are based on
the physical properties of
semiconductors which provide which are
materials which enable you to control
and manipulate the flow of electrons
yeah right to transport energy or
information but they're one of the goals
in the future is to convert from
electronics to photonics to instead of
electrons being the carrier let light be
the carrier of information and energy it
has lots of advantages it moves faster
and it doesn't dissipate energy as much
as electrons do now you need a wire but
you know you wires already exist they're
called fiber optic cables those are
potential you have wires for light now
you need the next important element you
need a semiconductor for light and it
turns out quasi crystal patterns seem to
be have certain ideal properties and
make them ideal semiconductors for light
better than a crystal pattern the
crystal network of the
what we call a photonic crystal so this
is taking advantage of again their
unusual symmetry properties the fact
that they're much more spherical and
much more symmetric than ordinary
crystals so the basis of an entire new
arm of the electronics industry or
photonics yes photonics industry yes
right so you know that's a subject which
is an idea which has been around for a
few decades and it's just beginning to
really take off we hope but we'll see
that's an exam or taking advantage of
this new new material is what we're
doing yeah yeah I mean that Paula is
really I'm speechless it's a really
fantastic story I love I love how many
different characters are genuinely does
sound like a work of fiction that
happens to have occurred in the real
world it felt like it - well I think I'm
really excited to see what happens next
I'll be I'll be keeping my ear to the
ground - to hear what's gonna be coming
out from the if there's gonna be any
more new materials that'll be found so
for the year for the listeners at home
where can they find the book I'm sure
there'll be a lot of people who will
want to read more into the story and and
find out more about the characters in
there and the discoveries that you made
along the last the last few decades of
research so where can they find the book
and what can they find yourself online
okay well and the book is available the
book is from Simon & Schuster it's
available on Amazon and and maybe in
local bookstores or you can make the
contact and learn a little bit more
about the story by going to my website
which is called second kind of
impossible dot-org second kind of
impossible without any spaces in it dot
org and there you can you know learn a
little bit more about what we're doing
and and also you know where to get the
book and all that so I think people I
hope people will enjoy reading the story
I've gotten very nice feedback on it so
far and and and and and you can also
write to me if you have any questions or
reactions I'd
to here where people think of it amazing
I'm absolutely certain that that people
will want to find out more I will make
sure that the link to your website and
the book on Amazon will be in the show
notes below and if I get any questions
sent through I will act as your envoi
your mineralogist envoi and I'll pass
the messages to yourself so to the
listeners at home if you do have any
questions feel free to contact me on my
usual socials Instagram Twitter etc etc
and I will make sure that Professor
Steinhardt get to them and I will try
and report back as accurately without
bastardizing the content as much as I
can well thanks so much Chris it's been
fascinating thank you so much for your
time well thank you Chris it's been fun
[Music]